we have this article from the post
millennial Biden's Surgeon General warns
that 13 year olds shouldn't use social
media because they are still developing
their identity
Chris Elson wrote Vivek Murthy says he
believes 13 is too young for children to
be on social media platforms because
kids are still developing their identity
what about puberty blockers
so I think this shows the hypocrisy yes
it does yeah clearly really fully
just straight out hypocrisy yeah so you
have Vivek Murthy saying um that
children should not be on social media
because they're still developing their
identities but he would also tell you
that girls who are minors should be able
to get abortions without parental
consent and also that children should be
able to determine their own gender
identity so I'm sure Jeff you're
familiar with the story of John money
yeah oh yes absolutely uh do you have
concerns I mean obviously you have
concerns for your for your children over
this
yeah I mean the way I put it to the jury
when I was put on the stand was very
simple I said you know if my sons go
with me they have a chance at a normal
life
if they go with her they have no chance
at a normal life and a good chance of
living a life of despair
and that's the choice that's the
Hobson's choice that we're giving all of
these children right and they're they're
so obsessed with puberty blockers
because the cure for gender dysphoria is
called puberty puberty is the cure for
gender dysphoria puberty is the process
by which you come to identify with the
social psychological and physical
aspects of your sex
that's what puberty actually is and so
they desperately have to block puberty
to maintain the gender dysphoria over 90
percent of these kids if you just don't
do anything just grow into normal adults
small proportion of them uh become gay
and uh in line with the normal
population and then a small percentage
of them continue to have problems this
feels like at least to a certain degree
some of this is experimentation like we
we know from the story of uh John money
and what he did to uh was it Brian and
David whether Brian and David that they
both ended up killing themselves in in
different ways yes and it's it's a it's
a horror story now that story is
particularly horrifying because uh John
money was forcing them to simulate adult
activities on each other when they were
very young children yeah so for those
that aren't familiar with this story I
think most people are but if you're not
basically you had uh twins I think
they're identical twins they're
identical yeah uh and there was a
botched circumcision so John money
convinced the parents you know it will
raise one as a girl one as a boy and
then I think almost immediately it was
uh was was Brian or was it it was David
David was the one who made to live as a
girl David knew that he was actually
male yes the whole time and it caused
Great distress so
that that's that's my fear in that
thinking though there is the argument
made by the left that that shows gender
identity is inherent in the individual
and that if a child is born male but has
a female Identity or wants to identify
socially as a female and you don't do it
you'll end up with a situation
well I I have a kind of an unusual take
for someone on the right I'm definitely
on the right
um and that I do think gender uh is in
in many ways socially constructed and
this always freaks people out right like
well how can you be a right well I
believe that but the social
characteristics that we have built up
around the biological subjects correct
yeah and in other words you you're born
male but you have to learn to be a man
your father teaches you how to be a man
you fall in the footsteps of your
forefathers and you learn how to be a
man to assume your duties and rights and
responsibilities as a man in your
Society then that has to be talked to
you right that kind of thing has to be
taught to you but like everything else
the left wants to make it either or in
these very strange ways you know sure
there is a genetic component probably to
gender identity there's a gen there's a
genetic component to all human behaviors
right
um it comes up a lot in the context of
being gay people say well people are
born gay they're not born gay
um there is a genetic component to being
gay
they know exactly what the genetic
contribution is because billions of
dollars have been spent on it it's
approximately equal to your to your food
preferences
and you're totally in control of what
you eat
so there's gen just because something
has a genetic component doesn't mean
it's outside of your volition yeah your
genetics can be altered by your
environment they can be turned on and
off I think this is phthalates and pcbs
there was a you know I've had the
conversation with a lot of conservatives
and you're bringing up good stuff this
is yeah exactly yeah we've had people on
I think even James Lindsey and I've
talked to a lot of these people who say
there's no such thing as trans kids and
I say I disagree with that I think you
we've we've already seen the stories
there was a there was a birth control
that women were taking that resulted in
their uh female babies masculine
masculinizing in the womb and then
invariably as they tracked and they grew
up to become lesbians and they're like
hey we just realized that this birth
control was actually doing this to the
babies in the womb yes in the event the
woman was got pregnant despite being on
birth control they had masculinized
female babies and so you take a look at
the Plastics this is why we've been
using glass bottles for for all our what
do we do with plastic bottles because
some people just don't care but I prefer
to put everything in glass because you
have phallets and pcbs and that's just a
couple of the endocrine disruptors that
we've we've got research on so my my
hypothesis on this is you know you had
Bill Maher who said
why are we seeing so many trans kids
um you've got so many in California but
not in Ohio so either what did he say
either there's something wrong between
the states or we're creating them or
something that effect and I'm wondering
if the reason we're seeing a massive
spike in this is I do think this is a
social component because we've actually
seen that in research but I think
another component of this may be that
we've expanded the use of plastics
plastic is over everything phthalates
and pcbs in all of our food then you've
also had these stories about uh birth
control getting in the water supply
can't be filtered out and then people
are drinking it
I think we are living in piles of our
own filth in cities which is making
Dirty Water full of endocrine disruptors
of any kind any kind and you're going to
end up with people with people who are
in the womb developing and their brains
are forming and either through some kind
of hormonal imbalance some kind of
chemical alteration through phthalates a
baby is born and they're they they have
it they have an inverted gender identity
that doesn't match their body you also
you can't discount the social contagion
though I mean where's no absolutely
we're seeing like a 4 000 increase
percent increase in girls who are
deciding that they are actually boys
we're seeing clusters of girls all
transitioning together and and there are
a lot of stories about people who have
taken their children away from these
School environments and their kids
immediately transition correct and it's
also very trendy in some places where my
son had been going to school in New York
City Trans was very trendy and some of
his friends were coming in like one day
they were furries and the next day they
were lesbians and then they were
actually trans and then somebody else
was trans because his girlfriend was
trans and she was a lesbian now and like
it would be a whole it was a whole thing
it was like a constant every day there
were like different identities going
around and it was very trendy to be part
of the whole identity thing it's really
empowering to get people to believe
you're someone you're not that's part of
why I became an actor it's incredibly
empowering they love it I love it
everyone then you get paid for it but
then these kids I think they just want
that empowerment part of it too though
is we're talking about puberty right so
Jeff you brought this up we were talking
about puberty what is puberty puberty is
the process by which it's you know
development it's the process by which a
child becomes an adult it's a
coming-of-age process right we've taken
away so many of the coming-of-age
rituals we've killed our Gods so you
know we don't have coming of age rituals
in our religion anymore at this point in
the United States that's not common we
don't have a lot of confirmations
anymore about Mitzvahs or anything like
this so what we have for our coming of
our main Coming of Age ritual in our
country right right now is coming out
you can come out as something that's
like the only the only American it's
it's the American coming of age right
it's it's our rite of passage right you
come out as part of your right of path I
always get your driver's license no it
used to be getting your driver's license
but now that's 16 it's 18. is it like
quinceanera thing yeah quinceanera
that's yeah that's like a in Mexico
right yeah in Mexico that kind of thing
I know that is there a male version of
that I don't know what they do down
there well you know you do like a 16th
birthday party but um it's not the same
kind of thing you know what I mean like
this is our main rite of passage it used
to be I remember when I was a kid and
the whole like everybody wanted to lose
their virginity as quickly as possible
this was like but that's very different
from what that's different right yeah
it's very different but now you can you
can go through a rite of passage of
coming out and what are the things you
get to do you get to change your name
you get to start choosing your own
clothes you get to dictate how other
people are going to treat you you know
you're going to treat you're going to
call me by this name you're going to
refer to me even when I'm not there with
these very specific you know phrases it
feels like uh a lot of RPG video games
your character will start off as like
training mode or whatever so actually
this reminds me of MapleStory which I
don't know if it exists anymore but your
character starts in like levels one
through ten you have no specialty and
then once you get to level 10 you get to
choose your class like what are you what
are you going to be and it feels very
much like what they're trying to do well
there's one thing I think video games do
play into the social contagion because a
lot of boys play girl characters in in
fps Shooters mainly because you just
don't want to look at a guy's ass
when you go to third when you go to
third person you want to see a girl's
ass when you're flat right but third
person you but yeah if you play it in
third yeah I switch to third person you
can play it you know with a girl
character it's it's more pleasing to you
SEC the other thing though you mentioned
these pcbs we can we can actually
objectively quantify that so the United
States Marine Corps has grip strength
data going back to the Revolutionary War
they administered grip strength tests at
tons Tavern when they commissioned the
Marine Corps so it literally goes all
the way back to to the very beginning so
they have the ultimate longitudinal data
set grip strength among men today is 30
what it was 50 years ago
not me though I got good grip hell yeah
it turns out grip strength is one of the
best proxies physical proxies for
testosterone levels wow so the Marine
Corps won't even let you go to recruit
training anymore unless you show up for
a year of physical training to prevent
training deaths that's how bad it is so
the handshake the handshake test that's
real it's a legit thing it's a legit
thing it's plastic I've heard that
hanging is some of the best things you
can do for a person like hang from a
tree branch and just well that's what
the Marine Corps has you do if you have
weep grips just hang really yeah hang
for 20 minutes before you get child you
don't get to eat until you hang wow
that's what they make you do yeah well
sperm counts also on the decline yeah
which is another great marker a
completely objective marker of
testosterone levels this is the crazy
thing so if you look back at like we
used to drink Mercury to try and cure
syphilis these things didn't work but
the Hope was that you'd poison yourself
so much that I don't know what they were
thinking yeah I can't I can't understand
this like the people would just die from
drinking it what made them think in any
way it would help them or like oh well
the simplest must have got them but uh
then we have asbestos yeah and asbestos
actually is fine until you disturb it
but then we started realizing like hey
if we're gonna start clearing out these
buildings and doing remodeling all of a
sudden people are getting mesothelioma
so we get rid of it now here's the
problem with pcbs they've warped our
mind
we are now in a as a society in a
delusional state
and when a person let's say a person
gets hypoxic you cannot save yourself
right that's why they say put on your
oxygen that's great before putting the
mask on somebody else yeah if our
society has been plagued by pcbs and you
wonder why it is that you've got to
divide between urban and rural why the
Democrats in the cities believe this in
people in the country don't perhaps it's
because the people in the cities are
gargling and swimming in endocrine
disruptors that people who are on weld
water are not and I grew up on well
water in a Farm and Ranch in Texas so
what happens then is as a society that
is assuming the interconstructors are
doing this yeah if half of the mind of
our society this this body has been
it was altered in some way yes how will
you make a sound decision to correct the
behavior a person who is I actually
never thought of that that's a great
point right our our minds uh so it it's
it's not just this issue I mean it's
also drugs and everything else sure so
it's like if you can't think you can't
think your way out of it right if if you
were on a plane
the reason they say put on your mask
before someone else's is because if
you're all hypoxic you die yes if one
person could get their mask on you can
take everything straight they can save
everybody but we're in a place now where
half the people aren't wearing their
mask and so when you're with your mask
on saying put the mask on they're
swinging at you in a rage and then just
collapsing you can't vote your way out
of it yeah you gotta appeal to the gut
that's the only way if the brain can't
understand or is incapable from
desensitization you can get their own
gut you know we we talked a little bit
earlier about the depopulation agenda
you know friends in Europe and they
always make fun of us in America for the
some of the crazy stuff here the
wokeness
the fact that we pay three percent on
our own money interest on our own money
and our own treasury is bizarre they
laugh about these things and I just tell
them I just tell them like
maybe you should have some mercy because
it's we're probably the most heavily
propagandized population in the history
of the world the most sophisticated
propaganda regime ever launched against
a people has been launched against
Americans and they can't actually see
reality right in front they'll deny the
evidence of their own senses it's it's a
bizarre experience
um and I I can tell you running for
office talking to Normie conservative
Republicans
many of them actually still believe the
Constitution constrains a government and
that we should make constitutional
arguments to restore the Republic and
you're like
Constitution has constrained the US
government in 100 years like it's it's a
completely irrelevant document like how
can you still keep saying these things
it's because they're heavily
propagandized we should not
underestimate how effective the
propaganda has been to Warp
uh well those visions that the issue is
you've got prominent
individuals who make a lot of money
just agreeing with whatever the machine
wants them to agree with so to go back
to the you know oxygen mask analogy if
half the people in this country are
inundated with pcbs and other chemicals
that's damaging their brain or or
causing them to you know just have
alterations to their mindset
neurodivergence as it were yeah then
someone comes along and says I don't
know about that but if I agree with them
they'll give me money
that's what's happening well the famous
observation that it's hard to get a man
to change his mind about something he
was being paid to believe it oh wow yeah
that's a good one it's a very simple
concept but you know the you know the
the basic operation of of prop modern
propaganda is to demoralize people but I
don't mean it in the sense of making
them feel bad I mean to literally remove
morals yes I was going to ask because
people often talk about demoralization
and have to half the people think you're
talking about low morale exactly when
you're talking about the removal of
removal of morals because you can't
understand reality without moral
reasoning this is also something that
Heidegger talks about this is why
artificial intelligence is impossible
because moral reasoning is required
right it's required to make judgments
about the world right but I wouldn't say
impossible I would just say it's not
going to turn out the way we want it to
a big part of what's been going on
though is that the uh no I'm sorry go
ahead no no it's okay I think that in a
lot of cases the goal of you know
whoever is doing this is to remove our
ability to make judgments that's right
you know they want us to not be able to
differentiate between right and wrong or
good and bad simply because they want
the order to maintain well because they
want to get their thing across you know
well it turns out that discriminating
between right and wrong is the is is
important to discriminating between red
white and blue falling down going
upstairs like the apprehension of
physical reality is informed by your
morality it turns out there's a
reflexive relationship between the two
and by removing this moral judgment you
can you can remove the ability people to
understand what's happening to them and
that's what's going on too with the drag
story hours and everything is you have
kids come in they look around and
they're like this is super creepy and
then the parents are like no this is
totally normal but explain the the AI
thing why do you think it's not possible
so
um what we're really doing with AI is
we're doing fancy curve fitting
so
um and we we put a nice name on it and
we do all stuff but what it is basically
doing is curve fitting to very
complicated functions
and it can mimic a lot of the
decision-making abilities of humans it
can it can be really effective if it's
layered so-called deep learning
where it's layered so you're doing
essentially curve fitting on curve
fitting on curve fitting on curve
fitting but what it can't do
is things that that humans do it cannot
look at its environment and make
judgments independently about its
environment like one of the hardest
problems in AI
is to teach a system to just recognize a
kitten
it's an it's a notoriously difficult
problem to get it to just optically
recognize a kitten something which which
a two-week-old newborn can do what do
you mean it can't recognize a kitten it
can't it turns out that kittens have a
fuzzy enough look that's very difficult
for them to discriminate it but yet a
child with the kinesthetic perception
once it holds and remember we're talking
about two week old infants yeah that
don't have object permanence
so when you remove it from their site
they think it doesn't exist anymore
that's why they get that's why you can
play peekaboo with kids because you
appear again out of nowhere right they
don't have object permanence so but they
you could teach a child that age to
discriminate a kitten but you can't
teach AI is very difficult to do we'll
get there I think though and one of the
also one of the hardest problems called
the the location problem what if you
just plop an AI down in a hallway and
get it to recognize where it is figure
out where it is this turns out to be
extremely hard without the contextual
information provided by innate human
knowledge about the world in some sense
what kind of what Kant was talking about
that there are categories of perception
by which we structure knowledge
that's not possible for AIS well I I
don't I think we just haven't developed
the technology to get there I think it's
possible that have you seen like the
Boston Dynamics robot yes I think you
can put uh some kind of algorithmic
learning uh system within it and let it
Mill about and eventually it'll start
discovering and mapping things and then
understanding and all that stuff no I
don't actually don't disagree that it
would do that but what I'm what I'm
disagreeing with is whether that's
intelligence
yeah let me give you an example I
suppose that goes to the question of the
Soul then ultimately sorta but actually
we can just restrict ourselves to just
mathematical logic you know in
mathematical logic there's two separate
categories of research one is called
Model Theory one is called proof Theory
when your computer is here do
mathematics or arithmetic they don't
understand what the numbers mean right
so it turns out that what mathematicians
are actually doing is they're creating
what are called formal languages
and these formal languages have three
particular elements that make them up
and they've been thoroughly studied
mathematical logic is like the
Linguistics of mathematics and studies
these languages they have one particular
property that natural languages don't
have
and that is that every grammatically
correct sentence is guaranteed to be
true
what do you mean by that elaborate so um
if you follow the rules of algebra
you don't need to know what the numbers
mean you'll get the right answer
as long as you followed all the rules
right you'll get the right answer you
could see symbols on a page and and know
that that was no that's called proof
theoretic reasoning so we're just using
grammar rule to simplify if I understand
that 3 as a symbol represents three
objects yeah you can represent that with
say sticks yes even if I did not know
what those represented if you knew the
rules of how the numbers you still get
the right answer yeah so that's how
computers do mathematics right the
computer doesn't know that two right
would be represented by two physical
right it doesn't know it two means it
doesn't know what it means but humans
usually do mathematics using model
Theory
where we the number means something in
mathematical logic a model is when you
actually assign meaning to the undefined
terms so if you're doing geometry you
have points and lines you give them some
meaning say a point is a DOT on a page
and a line is a straight A straight uh
you know ruler on a page you give it a
meaning well here's the amazing thing
about formal languages
um that any sentence that's
grammatically true just for proof Theory
without any meaning to the terms is
guaranteed to be true in all models
so it turns out no matter how you define
points and lines if the axioms are true
in that model all of the sentences will
be true too so all the theorems are true
that's not true in natural language
so what the AIS are really doing is a
kind of proof theoretic
way of trying to make their way in the
world it's not doesn't understand the
meaning of what it's doing this is uh
that's what you would find terrifying
about them I find the whole thing
terrifying because I think where we're
headed is I saw an ad for a program that
can
generate any video so everybody's been
playing with these various AI model
model uh art programs there was like
stable diffusion we did a bunch of bits
on the show where we like you know
Donald Trump hugging Joe Biden and the
photo's awful and doesn't really work
but now you've gotten what's that what's
that really popular one that everybody's
using at GPT no no no the picture
generator oh my God I use nightcaps
uh what was that you just bumped us off
it's because I took the mic off and I
just hit the wrong button oh okay so
sorry everybody's saying mid Journey but
there's another app that can make videos
now obviously there's a big controversy
over deep porn where that streamer was
watching it and uh so I think where
we're going is
right now what we can see basically the
tools that exist it is entirely possible
to combine these things and say okay
give me the scene it's a it's a bar and
there's three guys and they're about to
have a fight yes you could create the AI
models then tell the machine to make
this scene with these models and it will
you will be able to write a movie and
then press go and it will apply the
script the character names the
description of everything I agree the
script can be put in and this is
possible literally right now all we have
to do is combine the components that
already exist and are purchasable you
can then take an existing script file
name description character sound of
their voice it's all in the script and
then the machine will render that for
you but here's the thing
that's technology today that we simply
need to connect it already exists yes
where we will actually go is you will be
sitting in your room and you'll be like
uh computer
make me a movie about Cowboys uh in 1870
and uh they awaken a dragon and he's got
to save his son and the Machine will
just generate everything instantly for
you right the scary thing to me that
about how nightmarish it is is we are
going to especially with Nora link and
VR we are going to tell the computer get
generate for me a world where I am the
king and everyone loves me and I have to
fight a dragon and then you put that set
on and you go into this soulless
masturbatory fake reality yes that's
where we're headed yes that's where
we're headed yes directly I agree with
all that the question that becomes what
is humanity and what do we want Humanity
to be and what do we feel our value is
and do we have a value Beyond how we can
entertain ourselves I read a great quote
a long time ago and it said if humans
ever shake hands with aliens they will
be congratulating each other not over
over not because they've overcome
nuclear weapons but but because they've
overcome the Xbox that is is everything
that we are doing as humans is to
trigger our dopamine yes you take a look
at how humans used to live and we talked
about with jackboxobic I think it used
to be the norm that you would be out in
the middle of nowhere struggling to find
food that you wouldn't always have
everything you needed then we figured
out how to basically isolate everything
so what do we do we take pure sugar
combine it with pure fat and then we
guzzle it down until our heart stops
working for yourself
I stopped doing that a while ago oh my
God I mean a dessert here and there is
fine but imagine this that we've taken
beets and we've extracted the sugar and
Hyper concentrated that we took an
orange which is delicious and healthy
and we smashed all that juice that one
wasn't even hard right that what we're
doing is whatever feels good but it's
just a light we're just basically
electrocuting ourselves over stimulating
until we die that makes me think we were
talking about earlier about morality
because I think some people conflate
morality and pain they think that if
it's painful that means that it's not
moral but the reality is a lot of
painful things are the moral thing to do
you thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time